just transparently lying. Obviously
>> This is confirmation. This is an illegitimate regime.
The Constitution, representative democracy, our republic is effectively
over. I truly believe this person is worse than Nick Fuentes.
They have a worse soul than Nick Fuentes. He is the one of the
worst human beings on the planet Earth.
I think I think the entire
right-wing like influencers sphere is against this. Like like
there maybe get Tim P on board with it,
but like both BAP and Fuentes are going in on Trump for your
Twitter clout. Like the the clouded up Twitter guys, I think
it's like over, man. A short time ago, the United States military
began
major combat operations in Iran. Our objective is to defend the
American people by eliminating eminent threats from the Iranian
regime, a vicious group of very hard, terrible people. >> Well,
that was the president of the United States a little bit earlier
today. Obviously, I just came back from Shabbat, from Sabbath
to the news of what is going on. And let's just say this, President
Trump is the most courageous commanderin-chief in modern American
history. There is no question about this. What he just did is
the bravest move by a president of the United States of my lifetime,
bar none, without a doubt. And today, I'm going to go through
exactly why he did what he did, why he did it, when he did it.
We're going to go through many of the objections to what he is
doing. >> So brave.
Like I said, Mike Tyson in his prime against a nine-year-old
with leukemia is so brave >> or affected by it. >> Let's
begin with this. The president of the United States made the
unbelievably
>> decision and was a brave decision to move to end the
threat against America and her allies in the Middle East. core
threat the Iranian regime that has been
>> Oh, Iran, guys. Iran was going to have ballistic missiles
and nukes any day now. They could threaten the US. They were
going to. It was going to happen for sure. 100%. >> Militating,
killing Americans and American allies since 1979.
President of the United States made to move to end the threat
against America.
>> he didn't just say military >> allies in the Middle
East. the core threat the Iranian regime that has been percolating,
militating, killing Americans and American allies since
I didn't know that was a word. H percolating and militating.
Nobody believes it's your current Nobody believes it's in America's
core interest anymore.
Nobody believes that. The Iranian government has been responsible
for the death of hundreds, if not thousands of Americans over
the course of time, ranging from the 1983 barracks bombing in
Lebanon via its proxyah
to the death of hundreds of American soldiers in Iraq during
the Iraq war.
The Iranian regime has also been responsible for the murder of
people >> You do have to go back 50 years. You do. ranging
from Europe to South America to obviously the Middle East where
it has activated its proxies against American allies, not just
Israel, but also including Saudi Arabia, UAE, and other countries
in the region. The Iranian government is the leading sponsor
of terrorism on planet Earth. It has been for Dude, uh, so many
people told us that neocons were dead.
They weren't dead. They were hiding somehow. Somehow, not unlike
Palpatine, the neocons returned. Okay. >> Decades, the
president decided to end that threat earlier this morning. >> Neocons
won. >> So, first of all, the idea again that only Nick
was saying that that the neocons were gone. Wait,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. That's not true.
That's not true. Literally every Dude, Destiny said that [__]
Zion said that.
So many people said the neocons were gone for so long. Oh, actually
a little bit big news.
Apparently, Iran has now confirmed that Ayatollah Kmeni has been
killed.
The Supreme Leader of Iran, uh, Iran was denying for a while.
It appears they are now accepting and announcing that the Ayatollah
has been killed. That's terrible. I don't really think it's terrible.
Um, I dude, I was listening to the silly series. Like I said,
she seems pretty convinced that Kamani is not remotely required
for the Islamic regime to maintain power. That there's going
this is going to take forever to play
and that like whether or not Kmeni is there, it it doesn't really
matter.
Like they're so entrenched everywhere. And I think it's also
been like massively
how much the people there
want to Yeah. I don't
I don't know. I don't know. Yeah, Diaspora will be happy about
this for >> Okay, some of you may be ahead of the news
where I am because again, I'm drinking from a fire hose just
having come off of the Sabbath.
>> Hey yo, Ben.
Hey,
the supreme leader of Iran
been up on the news today. Some of you may be ahead of the news
where I am because again I'm drinking from a fire hose just having
come off of the
>> Why is Why does he say like that? Why you guys say like
that? Ben, what are you doing? Ben, also Kmeni was a Shia religious
leader. So the Shi are not going to be fans of the religious
leader being bombed. I see. >> What's the geopolitical
reason for the United States to be involved? Iran acts as a linkage.
The current regime acts as a linkage between China and Russia.
It provides enormous amounts of oil to the Chinese machine. It
it gives the Russian war machine shahed drones and of course
it acts as a check and balance against the United States in the
Middle East. That is what Iran historically has done. In order
to understand what President Trump is doing geopolitically, you
have to understand the consequences if he didn't do it. If President
Trump had left the Iranian regime in place after it murdered
32,000 of its own citizens in violation of the president of the
United States's red line. if the Iranian regime continued to
rebuild. >> Okay, so this is No, no, no, no, no. This is
total. I'm I'm telling you when people when people tell you this,
the reason the reason the United States gives weapons to Ukraine
is not because protecting democracy is good.
Okay, protecting democracy is good. It is is what you want to
market on. Okay,
if they told you what their actual intentions were, you would
you might not like it. It wouldn't sound as good. Okay, if if
the US came to you and said, "Well, actually,
we don't think that these people can really win a war long term,
but and we could support them and we could like make sure they
win overwhelmingly." But if we actually just like sort of trickle
weapons into them, it will bait Russia into invading. It will
keep Russia trying to invade and we can actually just totally
obliterate the Russian economy by letting them run into a meat
grinder over and over again. Yeah, tons of Ukrainians will die.
Yeah, tons of Russians will die. But it's like we are actually
going to grind their economy to a halt, be incredibly powerful
for us. If they tell you that you they sound evil, they sound
crazy, but that's what it is. Okay? All of its military and nuclear
facilities, which is what it was doing if it continued to do
that. And President Trump did nothing. The geopolitical consequences
for the United States would have been disastrous. Why? Because
China looks at that and maybe they make that move on Taiwan.
Russia looks at that and maybe they really up the ante in Ukraine.
President Trump is the president who will not allow under any
circumstances the threat of force to go away. He understands
better than anyone that the credible threat of American military
force, he doesn't like using it. He doesn't want to use it. But
the credible threat of American military force is the thing that
keeps America in the driver's seat globally. That is what he
was doing. He is pushing China off the ball with regard to Taiwan.
He is pushing Russia off the ball with regard to Ukraine. And
yes, of course, he is getting rid of the cancerous regime into
Thran, which has spread its terror tentacles all over the world,
predominantly in the Middle East, but yes, also in Europe, where
it has pursued terrorist attacks. Yes, in South America. Yes,
in Latin America.
>> Actually, how many times do people have to watch the
same playbook?
How many times do people have to watch It's literally all of
the same things over and over again.
Same playbook every time. It's like so tired.
I you know what the most depressing thing to me is?
I feel like within my lifetime I'm gonna have to hear this same
thing about Saudi Arabia.
I feel like I'm going to have to hear about how like listen Saudi
Arabia just will not stop doing terrorist attacks on Israel.
And I know that they were our ally for a little bit. And I know
that I feel like I'm I'm almost positive that within my lifetime
I'm going to hear the same thing about Saudi Arabia. Yes. I think
at some point there will be a breakaway there.
I'm sorry. I do think that uh it'll be a pretext certainly for
taking parts of
I understand Saudi are total allies right now. I understand that.
But they're now alone in that region. Yeah. I don't think Egypt's
really doing anything either.
There's no question.
Oh, Turkey. That's true. I think
that probably is. No, you're you're probably right actually,
Lily Luna, that Turkey is the actual like um the next geopolitical
rival of Israel.
So
yeah. Yeah. Okay. A bunch of people are saying no. No. Turkey
is like objectively the the Eastern Mediterranean is like objectively
where their next theater is going to be
there.
while Saudi Arabia has oil, it has literally nothing else. It's
just sand. It's literally just sand. Okay? Like nobody nobody
want to be in Saudi Arabia. Come on, man.
Literally nobody nobody wants to be there. It's [__]
It's just sand. It sucks. Saudi Arabia
>> Opportunities that are blown, historically speaking,
lead to significantly worse after effects, historically speaking,
not sometimes, every single time. Bill Clinton failing to kill
Osama bin Laden in the late 1990s when he had him in the crosshairs.
The consequence was the USS 911. The
unwillingness of the West to topple the Bolevik regime in its
earliest iterations in Russia failing to sufficiently support
the whites against the reds in Russia led to a full century of
Soviet sponsorship of mass murder.
The United States's unwillingness
to help Shanghai fight back against the communists in China has
led to the rise of the Chinese Communist Party responsible for
not only the deaths of tens of millions of its own citizens,
but the main geopolitical threat facing America. Oh. Oh.
Ben Ben Shapiro sports
Kaishak. Is it Kang today? [__] >> In other
words, the deaths of tens of millions in China has led to the
rise of the Chinese Communist Party responsible for not only
the deaths of tens of millions in China. A full century of Soviet
sponsorship of mass murder.
>> The United States is un >> I know I know some
lefties in my chat are going to lose it at that. I noticed I
saw Hassan freak out over was it the cat Abua? Abu Guzala I can't
I don't know how to say her name breaking out over that woman
um saying she wants to defend Taiwan
bro that's
willingness to help Shanghai fight back against the communists
in China has led to the rise of the Chinese Communist Party responsible
for not only the deaths of tens of millions of its own citizens
but the main geopolitical threat facing America today. In other
words, when you have an opportunity to effectuate serious change
at relatively low cost, you do it. And that's what President
Trump is saying. He's saying, "We're not going to put hundreds
of thousands of troops on the ground and just effectuate a regime
change. We are going to take out the people who are most threatening
to you now. Go do the thing. Now go take control of your own
country." That's what he was doing in that magnificent speech
earlier today. The best
speech, in my opinion, of President Trump's presidency.
The best the best speech of Oh my god, where's the bath tweet?
Hold on.
Just thumbs down. And then he says speech is literally 2004 boilerplate
could have been drafted by AI collating agitation from that time.
Like literally the agit prop from 2004
if you just had an AI trained only on that.
That's that speech. And Ben Shapiro's like, greatest speech of
all time, man. Greatest speech of all time, man. That's such
an awesome
Yes. Yes. Donald Trump, you said every one of my talking points,
Donald Trump. Thank you. Greatest speech of Donald Trump's presidency.
>> Truly presidential stuff. >> This guy is like
the This guy is like the Nick Fuentes antagonist, the Nick Fentes
rival on Twitter, like for for right-wing influence. This is
like Nick Fuentes's rival who is kind of pro- Israel in like
a covert way. Okay. Nick Fentes always calls this guy
for that exact reason. And even this guy can't get out and be
like on he can't be like, "Oh, this is great." He's got to counter
signal it, but Ben won't. Ben can't from the president. >> Bill
Crystal co-wrote might have. >> So, you have an incredible
opportunity, a unique opportunity
geopolitically.
You have a necessity to do this because if you do not do this,
China takes the lead.
And this is also true with regard to, for example, Afghanistan.
The reason that Vladimir Putin decided to invade Ukraine is because
the United States withdrew like ignaminious cowards from Afghanistan
under
the pusilanimous President Joe Biden. Donald Trump under a Donald
Trump negotiated agreement like just transparently lying.
Obviously lying.
God, I hate I truly believe this person is worse than Nick Fuentes.
They have a worse soul than Nick Fuentes. He is the one of the
worst human beings on the planet earth. I hate Ben I there is
nobody I hate more than Ben Shapiro. I hate Ben Shapiro with
a burning passion. I hate Ben Shapiro.
I hate him. Does not play like that. He does not play like that.
President Trump is a uniquely
because why why do we hate Ben Shapiro? Because he runs cover
for things while explicitly knowing what he's running cover for.
while explicitly knowing how bad things will get. While while
being very aware of how wrong it is to do, he does these things
for money. He has no soul. He sold his soul completely. Okay,
that's what makes Ben Shapiro so bad. He knows exactly what he's
doing the whole time and does it anyway.
Testosterone fil. >> I'll take smart and like
smart and
I can't take like smart
st building your career on principles off the bat and then totally
ignoring and and forgetting those principles so that you can
make a buck. That's like
it's so to me with this guy
>> old president there's no question about this. The president
of the United States >> like this would be like if if Fuentes
I I do feel like this would be now with with Ben you could argue
that his whole career has always been about supporting Israel.
Also, he's been consistent the whole time and he's just swapped
his opinions to support Israel as much as possible. That's probably
fine. Maybe he's not been inconsistent that way.
Um, but this to me is like when I read his 2015 thing on why
he can't possibly conscient voting for Donald Trump, he lists
a whole bunch of reasons. All of the bad things that would come
to pass over the next like 8 to 10 years, okay, with Donald Trump,
every single thing that Ben pointed out has come to pass.
But the only thing that actually mattered to him was that Donald
Trump, he didn't think Donald Trump would be a good ally to Israel.
And then he was, and then all of those other things didn't matter.
Um, Israel hacked popular Iranian prayer app, sends out messages
to potentially millions of Iranians. Help has arrived.
I I can't help but feel like
they've like there's two I'm of two minds on this. Part of me
thinks they're completely missing the uh the mark on this and
that that like this is going to have negative effects that they're
they're continuing to propagandize like there's going to be a
mass uprising.
I don't know if they think I I feel like they're off the mark
and it's not going to work. But also, why would they be doing
stuff like this if they didn't have an idea that there was something
going on that there was like a seed there that they could water
and make work? Do you know what I'm saying? I I don't know.
That's crazy. has that is a dude with coones for sure and what
he is doing here is transformational transformational
if you understand the entire politics of the Middle Eastern region
and you understand the linkage between China Iran Russia and
you also understand Iran's sponsorship of every major terrorist
group in the region essentially from the Houthies down in Yemen
tobah in Lebanon
to Shia militias in Iraq
to rebell rebellious forces in Jordan
to rebellious forces pretty much everywhere else in the Middle
East.
You understand that a once-ina-lifetime opportunity to end the
regime is on the table. And so what we've seen from this ballsy
president over the course of >> I think this is like the
least ballsy move. Donald Trump has nothing to care about anymore.
He doesn't care about his popularity. He doesn't care about any
of that, right? Donald Trump doesn't give a [__]
about that [__] His popularity doesn't matter to
him. He's got his final term. Um, he's obviously not doing well
healthwise, okay?
It it literally
it literally doesn't matter. And this was Israel's last chance
to get regime change, right, in Iran? Like, they have they have
every
incentive to do this now because their numbers are also in the
tank. Their numbers are not getting any better anytime soon.
And they'll never have another chance to like shape opinion like
this to get this stuff to to happen. the last few months are
a change of regime in Venezuela effectively because if you're
squeezing them so hard that they squeak and they're basically
under America's control that is a regime change. You are seeing
that attempted now in Iran.
You are seeing that probably going to happen in Cuba.
You're watching America remake the world in its own interest,
in its interest because it is good for America when terrorist
regimes that oppose America and shout
>> uh what it's actually good for is Donald Trump's pockets.
Okay. A lot of wealthy Cuban donors who really want Cuban the
Cuban regime overthrown. There are a lot of very wealthy donors
to like pro-Israel donors who want the Iranian regime overthrown.
Donald Trump's going to continue to get his pockets lined because
he is a corrupt piece of
literally it. That's it. It's super It's super simple. It's super
easy. Donald Trump can get a lot of money by doing this. He can
just make all of the money. It's in Donald Trump's interest.
That's that's who that's who wins. What lessons have you taught
the Middle East? Like I feel like you've taught every person
in the Middle East that it doesn't matter what you do. It doesn't
matter
what you do at all.
You can survive. You need
I I don't think they could play the game. It's one of those things
where it's like I I do feel like I feel like we're going to see
a rash of like terrorism again in like 5 to 10 years that's going
to make like the ISIS period there where they were, you know,
doing random acts like random splinter cell attacks. I think
it's going to make it look like um
child's play. I think we're going to hit 5 to 10 years from now,
we're going to hit a rash of like terror attacks based on the
repeated destabilizations of these countries in the Middle East
that are going to be it's going to be [__] crazy.
That's very scary. >> A lot of people are trying to cite
George Washington, suggesting that this is all about a permanent
alliance, that permanent alliances are bad and we shouldn't go
abroad in search of enemies to destroy
the world is a lot smaller than when George Washington was president
of the United States. And we should note that even
I just don't know how much I care about the opinions of diaspora
space ghost, right? I just don't know how much I I care about
the long-term material conditions of the people who live in the
area, right? Is that I I just don't know how much I care about
the opinions of >> And shortly after >> diaspora
are always going to be against the previous regime, right? No
matter >> Washington was president of the United >> That's
like that's like why they're not in the country anymore. Like
they feel chased out of their countries by these these regimes.
They're always going to be against them. It's it's always going
to be the way it is. So the question is right now is this in
America's interest? The case for no is pretty weak. What is the
thing that is not in America's interest? Iran Iran's regime changing.
How is that? Please explain. That's that's the question that
that critics
No. No, that's not the question. You are wanting a change from
the status quo. You have to explain why it's in America's interest
and all you've done is explain why it's in Israel's interest
and then pretend that that's in America's interest. That's all
you've done. Well, actually, they're a real threat to America.
No, they're not. They haven't been for a long time. They are
no threat to America. There the only way they're a threat to
Americans
is possibly
the only way you can make this argument is saying that there
are American dual citizens living in Israel. Like it's a more
common spot for American dual citizens to live and they attack
Israel and there's a chance that when attacking Israel they would
kill American citizens.
That's like the only argument and I I just think that argument
probably holds for a lot of other places. I don't think it's
a good argument to make.
But overall, they're like not really that much of a threat. If
I think you could defend bombing centrifuges.
I think that's like the absolute utmost extent to which I I'm
like willing to accept that there's some sane s same discussion
to be had. You could you could probably argue for bombing centrifuges
and preventing a nuclear program from proceeding.
Okay,
I don't like it. I I would I would be against it if I were American,
but I think it's at least a rational discussion to have, right?
It's like a not totally
discussion to have. This though, the the regime change stuff.
I do think it's a stupid decision, stupid discussion to >> Answer
here. How is it not in America's interest for Iran's regime to
change?
Please explain in detail.
Please explain because that is the that's the question that needs
to be asked. So, the reason I'm interested in the I watched Nick
a lot about 3 years ago and he would talk consistently about
like Israel's foreign policy, how BB came up with it when he
first was elected prime minister. He he basically paid some people,
got some people together, drafted a memo on Israel's new foreign
policy
dictates for the Middle East. Okay, so that's the clean break
Uh, a clean break, a new strategy for securing the realm. Okay.
Commonly known as the clean break report is a policy document
that was prepared in 1996 by a study group led by Richard Pearl
for Benjamin Netanyahu the then prime minister of Israel when
he first was elected prime minister of Israel. Okay. Which is
right before they elected um eventually after him they they start
electing Chiron for the same party but he's the first Lud prime
minister I think right after audac
failed peace talks.
They go in the opposite way. clean break stuff is kind of the
greater Israel stuff kind of but not by name. Okay. So it's the
idea that that Israel had pursued a path of peace and that peace
wasn't possible and that what they needed to do was convince
other people that the rest of the Middle East had to be ruined
and and like fment wars or just strife in these other countries
so that they'd never be able to present a threat to Israel again.
that Israel needed to be offensive, not defensive, to start attacking,
not defending, not not trying to be like somebody who could like
operate with these partners. And by doing that, they basically
target and it's literally in this where they like we will actually
target like these specific states. It was Iraq, then Syria, then
Iran. The report was adopted and serves as the foundation for
modern-day Israeli global affairs. And Fuentes leans into this,
right? And I think the the thing that needs to be said is this
isn't a
Fentes, I think, tries to argue this. He doesn't do a great job
of highlighting it. It's not a conspiracy. It is just the foreign
policy of Israel and and like basically a strategy for negotiating
with the United States and getting things from the United States.
Like manufacturing um I guess Dude, I sound like such a leftist.
like manufacturing consent for a for from the United States,
the American people, for what they want to do because this it's
just their foreign policy. It's just the way they they interact
with the world. And I'll say it, okay, the goals of this whole
report, the the of the clean break report, okay, the goals were
regime change in Iraq, Syria, and Iran. BB1
this this strategy was adopted and has successfully been implemented
and every single goal of this strategy has been accomplished.
BB1
I I truly believe this like thinking about it he put a 30-year
plan into place and he executed every element. Okay, maybe are
the chosen people cuz
who's been this effective in glob in like geopolitics ever in
the modern era who's ever been effective on the level of BB Netanyahu?
There's not a single person. There's nobody. There's not a single
person anywhere. It's like total BB victory.
And like I don't like that. I I think BB Netanyahu is a bad person,
but I I hope people open their eyes that like BB has totally
won the whole time. Also, with the death of Kamani, you can bet
your bottom dollar
that BB's winning the next election. BB might have huge, huge
landslide margins in the next election. Okay? BB's getting everything
he ever wanted. He is the eternal leader of Israel. He won in
every possible way. Okay? Yes. the planning, the execution, it's
unmatched. It's unparalleled. Nobody's even close to this guy.
That's it. Israel is targeting the opposition leaders in Iran,
too.
I again, so one of the things that um that Fuentes quotes out
of this report, and I'd have to actually we maybe should read
the whole thing, is that the goal for all these countries is
that they will be bulcanized.
They will be broken up. the fact that they will that they have
multiple different ethnic groups in all these places in Lebanon,
in Syria, in Iran, in Iraq, that will be used and weaponized
to turn these places into a collective of tribes with flags,
right? As in they will never rise up. They will always be like
these low technology, low economic status groups who are incapable
of rising up. Yeah. Anti-panarabism basically. Yes. They'll never
be capable of rising up and joining together because they are
all different like waring coalitions.
Yeah. Ban two stance, whatever you want to call it. Yes, that's
the goal. And with the with the destruction of the Iranian regime,
I do believe it's in their interest that there is no no like
standing successful person who can go in there and do something.
I think that's why they keep trying to prop the Sha up. It's
like why they try to tell Western people like, "Oh, the Iranian
people yearn for the return of the Sha the Sha's son." It's like,
no, that's they literally hate the sha. There's not a single
person. There's like not any real support for the Shaw in Iran
at all. It is totally fake. It's totally astrourfed. Okay. Doesn't
exist.
That's much easier to do with Arabs. It is. It is. They hate
each other.
Oh god. Today's military strikes on Iran, carried out by the
United States and Israel, mark a catastrophic escalation in an
illegal war of aggression. bombing cities, killing civilians,
opening a new theater of war. Americans do not want this. They
do not want the the war. They do not want another war in pursuit
of regime change. They want relief from the affordability crisis.
They want peace. This is the best way to market against this.
By the way, you tell me I can't have healthcare, but unfortunately,
once again, we are bombing the Middle East. You're spending billions
and billions and billions of dollars bombing the Middle East,
and you tell me I can't have healthcare, but you're bombing the
Middle East again. Again, again. And you're creating a power
vacuum in the Middle East through which you can like totally
you can totally get justifications once the terrorism starts
from all of the the like from the massive quality of life destruction.
Once the terrorism starts, you'll be able to just redo the Patriot
Act. Do we live in a loop? Is time actually a flat circle? We
just I'm just watching this all unfold again and again and again
and again and again and again and again. This is forever. It's
forever. It's always I'm focused on and by the way, none of this
should ever be taken as
as like explicit, you know, I I am never going to shed a tear
for the Islamic regime, the Islamic Republic, sorry, for the
Iranian regime. I'm not I'm not shedding a tear for them. I don't
I don't particularly care about the people who took that country
over and turned it into a theocracy. I don't think they're good
people.
I'm basically just talking about how it's incredibly difficult
to push people out with that much power and have anything positive
happen.
Okay,
let's read the rest of the tweet. I'm focused on making sure
that every New Yorker is safe. I've been in contact with our
police commissioner and emergency management officials. We are
taking proactive steps, including increasing coordination across
agencies, enhancing patrols on sensitive uh of sensitive locations
out of an abundance of caution. Additionally, I want to speak
directly to Iranian New Yorkers. You're part of the fabric of
the city. your neighbors, small business owners, students, artists,
workers, and community leaders. You will be safe
Just admit you support the Yeah, just admit you admit you support
the Ayatollah. What do you want women to be?
H there's like that girl school that got bombed or something.
I'm just sitting here like
those women weren't free. Okay, that's the price of freedom right
there. Those women would never be free. They'd have to like cover
their hair. They they'd never be able to drive. they'd be secondass
citizens in that country forever. Okay? So, even if that school
was struck, and I'm not saying it was because the Iranian regime
are liars, okay? I just I appreciate, by the way, I appreciate
people saying stuff like, "Well, the Iranian Iranian regime are
just liars cuz that's how I feel about the Israeli regime." And
so, if that's just on the table and we never get called like
racist for saying that, I'm cool with that. Okay? I'm cool with
that. We'll just I'll say I always I always assume Israelis when
they speak they're lying. When the Israeli regime talks, they're
lying. And if we're going to make that assumption about both
sides, I'm totally good with it. Anyway, there's a response from
Bill Aman. Oh, this is going to be this is going to be well-rounded
and reasonable. So, let me get this straight. You support the
Kamini regime that killed 38,000 protesters. They really did
do this. I'm reading it in a tone, but they really did do this.
It was like a brutal, totally insane crackdown that they didn't
just do. They actually advertised how many people were piling
up in like morgs and hospitals and like dead in body bags explicitly
to make it clear like if you are protesting we will kill you.
They've never done that before. That's like a brand new thing
that they've never done before. They explicitly were like advertising
how many protesters they were killing. Not saying it like that.
What they were saying was actually these are all MSAD agents
but it's like tens of thousands of people. It's like thousands
of people on the cameras. Like thousands of body bags getting
sacked up. Probably like hundreds actually. But when you go to
the different angles and stuff, you could say thousands. And
they're like, "These are all MSAD agents."
Kind of saying that if you're protesting, we think you're a MSAD
agent, and if you're a Msad agent, we kill you. So if you're
protesting, put it together, right? Yeah, you may be correct
about the prediction of future terrorism coming our way. Well,
it's Yeah, it's going to be everybody.
There were like 7,000 deaths. I think the 30,000 death mark is
is I've heard it's accurate. I'll I'll defer to my because she's
put a whole bunch of like stuff in in the uh research channel.
She's been following this. I do think tens of thousands is accurate.
I I think last I saw.
So I'll I'll defer to my wand on this if she's if she's around.
Okay. So overthrowing the regime is justified. How do you do
it? Um you would need to have some sort of like some sort of
opposition. Some sort of like Yeah. Any kind of opposition. Unfortunately,
once you have like the level of crackdown on this thing that
Iran has, I think probably your best bet is exporting freedom
maximally, like in a capitalist sense, as in bringing these people
into a capitalist system, trying to industrialize their country,
trying to get them to produce things, trying to get them on board
with the modern system. Okay,
I think that's the way you do it. I think so, but I'm not totally
sure. It's really difficult. I'm just saying that this way, this
like bombing route seems to have failed every single time it's
been attempted. Right? If your if your argument is like, well,
what do we have to do? We just have to if you're going to make
the acceleration here's what I'll say. If you're going to make
the accelerationist argument from Iran from the comfort of your
home in the US or Canada, then shut the up about anybody making
accelerationist arguments in your own country. Okay? Never criticize
Aspen Gold again. Never criticize anybody around him again. If
they're going to make accelerationist arguments and you're going
to make it for Iran, then be willing to accept it for your country.
Okay? Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Anyway, okay. Don't be an accelerationist with other people's
countries and then for your country be like, "Well, actually,
that's wrong. That's you can't do that here. I live here. I don't
want to I don't want to deal with accelerationism where I live.
I kind of I like the status quo a little bit, actually. Very
[__] up." Okay. I don't care though. You cannot do
this. This is uh not good. Okay. Got to stay got to keep yourself
under control.
I'm sorry.
You are out for this stream.
I You got to control yourself. If you can't control yourself,
if you're going to If you're going to be anti-semitic explicitly,
I'm not going to let you be here. Okay? Wait, that sounded bad.
If you're going to be anti-Semitic, I can't let you be here.
Okay?
Don't do it implicitly. I'm not saying do it implicitly. I'm
not saying that.
I'm not saying that.
I just meant you were very overt in your anti-semitism such that
I couldn't ignore it.
You know what I'm saying? Like I could miss something if you
were being covert and then that would be me missing it. If I
catch it and you're being covert, I will also ban you. Okay.
The groer segment hasn't even started. But all the people here
who would dislike Israel enough to be anti-semitic are all leftists.
on one that has taken away women's rights and freedoms from the
Iranian people. It's always this. Never never let somebody moralize
to you about like American military objectives, American foreign
policy. American foreign policy will never be dictated by these
guys are bad. These guys are mean. They don't like us. These
guys don't like us. They're mean. That's not how American foreign
policy works. That's not how any country's foreign policy works.
You do not have the resources to police the morality of the entire
planet.
Even American uh even America at its absolute height economically,
militarily did not have the resources to police the entire planet.
And this is obvious. After World War II, America had the only
like real functioning productive economy in the world for a decent
amount of time. Okay? And they also had more military buildup
than any other country. America could have done actual imperialism.
You want to know what what country could have actually taken
over the world? It's America after World War II. America could
have gone in after World War II and totally ripped the entire
planet,
but they didn't have the resources to hold any of the territory
they might take, right? So, they did it economically through
soft power because they didn't have the population or or even
the the military resources to be that spread out over the entire
planet. Okay. Yes. They they did it through soft power. They
didn't do it through um they didn't do it through military might.
50 50 coups in 50 years. Sure. Sure. I understand the leftist
argument. I understand it. It's through soft power, though. If
if the if the United States wanted to do some SCOPS to get rid
of the Iranian regime, then I'm fine with that cuz that's far
cheaper. That's more man like manhour intensive. You want to
try to do soft, you want to try to do scops to get rid of that
regime, go ahead. Yeah. Soft power like as in not not overt,
not directly coercive,
but like covert.
Giving a couple hundred,000 to a militia here and there, right?
Anyway, you keep going and then you call our efforts to destroy
the evildoers a catastrophic escalation. It is. And this moralizing
is just it's just sad. It's just sad. It's not how politics works.
Okay. God, I need to read more. I actually need to get more into
politics. I need to read more political stuff.
But like not I don't I don't want to read like gay books. I want
to go and like find these couple of think tanks and just start
reading their papers. Cuz after with this whole clean break memo
thing, I'm like, dude, these think tanks actually have way more
power, are shaping thought way more, shaping policy, shaping
the way the government actually works. This is what you need
to actually look at is this stuff. I understand some people don't
like I understand a lot of people don't like Fentes. Um I understand
that he's anti-Semitic. Not going to say he's not anti-Semitic.
Not going to say he's not racist. Not going to say he's not misogynist.
He's all of those things. This is purely about This is I'm giving
you my non-emotional plea. This is purely about foreign policy.
He's been consistently saying these things are going to happen
for foreign policy the entire time. And by the way, I don't think
he was doing this anywhere near as much in the first Trump regime.
He wasn't talking about how Trump was going to bomb Iran during
the first Trump regime or he wasn't doing it like seriously.
He was saying in the future we'll go to war with Iran almost
certainly. But I think he I think he switches up based on Trump's
moves. And he's been consistently saying this. A lot of other
right-wingers are pushing against him. He just consistently keeps
saying, "Here's the here's the playbook. Here's the playbook.
Here's the playbook." And I just I do want to hear him do a little
bit of a victory lap on,
"Hey, the foreign policy predictions seem to be golden."
I don't know what to tell you. Uh I can't I can't explain to
you how wrong you are here, unironic positist, but yeah, like
Nick is literally advocating every single day on his stream to
not vote for Republicans.
He is the strongest Republican ass sorry the strongest Democratic
asset right now. Okay, by far. He is doing the most to get Democratic
politicians elected of any person of any American living. All
right, he is sitting here and he's going, "You are a total mark."
He has a massive audience and he's saying, "You are a total mark
if you vote for Republicans in these midterms. You are a total
[__] loser if you vote for Republicans in these midterms.
You are a [__] if you vote for Republicans in these
midterms."
Over and over and over again. First, my name is Nichol.
>> Okay, I need to go get water, so I'll be right back.
>> Good evening, everybody. You're watching America First.
My name is Nicholas J. Fuentes. We have a great show for you
tonight, and I wish it was under better
Normally, I'd say I'm excited to be here with you, but
this is very interesting turn of events. And tonight we're here
with an emergency broadcast, a special Saturday episode here
on the weekend
to discuss the historic world changing events of last night.
I'm sure as you all know, we are now living in a new
As Oliver Anthony would say, we are living in a new world.
Last night, the United States and Israel launched a joint attack
against Iran.
And make no mistake about it, this should be made unequivocally
clear right now. This is a regime change war. That is what the
president said. That is what it is. And so the reason I say this
is because last year when Israel and the United States engaged
Iran for the first time directly as they did in Operation Midnight
Hammer and the so-called 12-day war in June of
By the way, there's another thing to be said here is when people
push back on Nick and they just say when he gives a foreign policy
take and they push back on him and go, "You're only saying that
because you're anti-Semitic and they don't engage with any facts.
You are harming
people. You are explicitly trying to use like an accusition accusation
of racism to discount criticism of Israel or critiques of Israel.
You are harming Jewish people when you do this. Okay?
Because then he gets to go and say, "Turns out when everybody
says I only say this cuz I'm I'm anti-Semitic." Well, it turns
out being anti-semitic made me correct again, right? He can run
with that whole thing. He can say, "Oh, I had the correct takes."
Now, I think he believes he just is the correct foreign policy
takes, right? that he's taken the everything into account and
he has the correct opinion on how things will work. And I don't
even necessarily think that he
how do I put it? He goes back and forth. I won't say that he
doesn't believe it's inherent in genetics or something to be
like some certain way. It's just based on the pros and cons for
Israel. That is what that is what the analysis is based on. The
pros and cons for the country of Israel, the express preferences
of the leader of Israel, right, and his party. That's what he's
basing it on. But a bunch of other people will say, "You're anti-Semitic.
Greater Israel is not a thing. They're not going for Greater
Israel. They're not like they're not trying to overthrow these
regimes. They're not trying to just like destabilize these countries."
Everybody will say that without looking at the foreign policy.
They'll just say he's anti-Semitic. And it's like, dude, I do
not know how to tell you this
in any other terms.
Stop trying to accuse this guy of being anti-Semitic instead
of engaging on the points. Just engage on the points,
please. you're you're actually hurting people by trying to do
the anti-mitic copout on this. >> It was contentious whether
we called this a war because of the endgame, because of the motive
attack. Uh but what should be made clear is that we are now engaged
against the Islamic Republic of Iran in a full-fledged regime
change effort. And this is ours. We bought this. We're in it.
This is our country now. This is the world. So tonight, we're
going to get into all of that. We're going to get into what is
happening in Iran. We're going to talk about the attack. We'll
talk about the prelude to it. We'll talk about the actual operation.
I really just have one thing to say to all of you, which is I
told you so.
I told you so. They said I was crazy when I predicted this two
years ago in 2024. I TOLD YOU this is exactly what would happen.
I have been saying it for
I was laughed at. I was attacked. They called me crazy.
Well, sometimes Chicken Little knows what he's talking about.
And I told you so. I said a vote for Trump is a vote for a war
with Iran.
>> Yeah, Shimu. Like the unfortunate thing,
is that his that's what I'll keep saying, okay? Ignore all of
his domestic takes. Ignore the the the overt racism, misogyny,
all this. just grapple with the foreign policy analysis and his
foreign policy beliefs and basically his prediction making off
of those beliefs cuz now it's the second regime change that he
said is basically BB's strategy like in this in this three regime
change plan that he made 30 years ago, right?
It's the it's the final regime change. Sorry, I say it's the
it's the third one technically, but the second one that he's
basically been talking to people about and and walking them through.
And it's like at what point do you just go, "Yeah, I'm pretty
sure the only goal of Israel is to have these neighbors be destabilized.
It's not to it's not to have them experience democracy and experience
peace and love and all of these things.
It's just they want them destabilized. We don't want actual rivals
around us." >> And I tried. You know that. I really
I went out there in August of 2024 and I actually made the demand
on Truth Social and on Twitter.
What's funny is like
I I truly believe Asmin also called it. Asmin is literally just
a total
He saw Nick say it and he decided to say it as well. Okay. That's
all Asmin does. That's all Asmin does. That's all he's capable
of doing
was this. I think that we we play too big of a role in other
count's military.
Like we're too interventionary. We we get too involved into other
people's business. Uh it's a waste of our money. The people there
probably hate us. Uh like where's really the upside here, right?
Stay out of it. Yeah. Exactly. Now, I'm not saying like we should
be totally isolationist, but I think that the level that like
that we try to play nation building, especially in places like
this, like you know, like Libya for example back in the day,
um what the or or Iraq. No, absolutely not. Yeah, it's too much,
man. Way too much. I am actually I am so happy this has happened.
I am just dramatically tremendously happy this has happened.
If it's about Venezuela, it's a little different. But, >> uh,
I know that, you know, obviously I've talked about it for a long
time about how big of a problem Iran is and >> He's going
to watch the he's going to watch his Fentes stream. It'd be totally
corrected. Okay. >> As Asmin go to watch his his leader.
Okay. Asmin Gold is like one of the super chatters to Nick's
show who constantly gets mocked for his opinions. You know it.
You know it. How many civilians murdered is the red line again?
I don't. We don't have red lines. Your your country doesn't have
red lines. Where does your country have red lines? Nowhere in
the entire world,
bro. I bet you how
where else are the red lines for other like genocides going on
for other like um major crackdowns on protests in authoritarian
regimes? Where are the red
Where are the red lines? Where does America have a red line for
any other country? Where do these red lines actually exist?
They seem to only exist when it comes to countries that are very
close to one country in the Middle East. That's the only place
America has red lines that actually affect them on foreign policy.
And all I'm telling you,
I might support fixing all genocides. Cool. But that's not the
point. Your point was shouldn't we have a red line here? I'm
saying your government doesn't have a red line. And your point
here is well, I might support fixing all genocides. I don't care
because your government doesn't. And that was my point. Your
government is not using the pro the crackdown and protests. They
don't believe that. That is not their actual rationale for doing
>> Is always part of the plan. Trump's ascendancy from
the very beginning. And when I say the beginning, I mean 2016,
it was always part of this plan. >> Okay. Well, if that
wasn't you, even less, I'm sorry. I was going off on you for
no reason. It's my bad. I apologize.
this plan by Israel made decades ago, perhaps centuries ago,
to terraform the Middle East and make it a place
um wait, why do you think ADHD runs me? Why do you think Kani
dead is good for American interests?
Can I ask that? Why do you why do you feel that Kani dying is
good for American interests? I want to hear your very nuanced
opinion on this because I think the the average opinion is something
like, well, Kmeni is a strongman ruler who rules with an iron
fist and as long as he's gone, the Iran the the Iranian regime
will fall. Bro, do you think they didn't have a plan for this
guy dying? He's old and sickly. They had a plan for this guy
being gone. And the entire like their entire ethos is one where
they're replaceable.
That is the entire ethos that like backs this Islamic regime.
the the entire thing they're doing, it's all about, hey, it's
next man up. It's literally this this thing is totally decentralized.
They built a totally decentralized autotocracy. Okay?
And I'll start with let's talk about what is happening. Let's
talk about what happened last night. We'll talk about what is
ongoing and then I want to rewind a little bit and talk about
how we got here because that is actually the real story. The
real story is the process. It is the long march to this war,
which, as I said, has gone on for decades between
>> The 30-year plan. I I hope I hope Nick can at least
admit that BB Netanyahu is the greatest diplomat in human history.
And you might hate him. I think he seems quite evil to me, but
easily the the greatest diplomat in human history.
Mchavelian intentions, sure. Mchavelian tendencies, sure.
diplomat. Yes. Hold on. Nina niner
BB. I'm I'm including it within that all the things that could
possibly be indicated by diplomacy or being Mchavelian.
He blackmailed people. He bribed people. He did whatever it took
to get what he wanted done. But he got it done. He got every
single objective accomplished that he needed to get accomplished.
And he did it all while maintaining rule under like conditions
like he he did it in a democracy. Why was I able to predict that
Trump would bring us to war in Iran and Trump voters did not?
Because Trump voters are part of the scam. They are suckers.
They were tricked because they listen far too much to what is
said online by influencers, which is effectively a form of soft
lobbying.
If you didn't see this coming, if you underestimated the possibility
or the inevitability that this would happen, it is probably because
your information diet, the opinion makers that you follow,
this isn't
he definitely voted for Trump. I don't believe he said he voted
for Trump even right after Trump won when there was every incentive
for him to like he celebrated Trump winning and he was like well
you know it's just I'm laughing I'm laughing at all these reactions
and I believe he's maintained that he didn't vote for Trump like
the entire time so if he didn't if he was saying it right when
it was like most profitable for him to say otherwise I don't
know I don't know why he would like make that up now or I don't
know why you would think he was lying
right like If h how am I trying to say this? He
if he was going to lie about this and say he voted and say, "Okay,
well, I didn't vote Trump and he's going to lie about it." Why
would he do that at the worst possible time? It's like very goofy,
right? An artifice which is put in front of you by special interest
groups. Why was this not on your radar? Why did you underestimate
the likelihood this would happen? It's because probably your
timeline has been curated by an algorithm to show you a very
particular
perspective, a very particular frame of the Trump administration.
And that frame is a scam. It is wrong. The reason I called it
right is because I didn't follow Trump's speeches and his influencers
and his cadre of soft. I followed the people he put into policy
deciding like policy decision makers. I followed the Steven Millers.
I followed Oh, I used to know the names. I'm not going to be
able to run the names of the under secretaries and stuff, but
this is like if you This is literally the way to do it. Oh my
god, I just realized uh
Joanna and Fentes have like the exact same way of looking at
this.
This is what Jo this is what the silly series does, too. And
I'm not saying this to discredit her. I'm sorry if that's how
it sounds. I'm not. It is just objectively the way you you see
what the intentions of an administration are. who's getting influenced
to do what. Like when Trump gets told this guy is the guy you
want to put in charge of some some element of foreign policy
or this element of domestic planning, that's Trump is being influenced
by somebody lobbying him and you could tell the interest that's
lobbying him by the person put in that position. It's like obvious
obvious paint by numbers analysis, right? But that's what he's
going to say. I I don't follow I don't look at, you know, anything.
I'm going to look at who's advising Trump and who he puts in
positions to like make decisions. his under secretaries and the
people who actually draft policy. That's what I'm going to look
at. >> Lobbyists
on social media, >> I followed the money. >> I followed
the institutional capture. I followed those associations
>> which are defining. >> And if you look very closely
at those >> on a very specific timeline, >> institutional
capture would be the people you're putting in. Then the money
would be the people who are, you know, lobbying you. It should
have been obvious that this was inex it wasn't going to go any
other way. But like I said, more on that in a moment. We're going
to start by talking about what >> um Yeah, that's exactly
what it would be like. Weasley little liar. Yes. Obama having
all of the the Wall Street guys as people, you know, lobbying
him and then he put pro Wall Street guys like in positions of
power and then when Wall Street, you know, when he has to make
that call on who's going to do what he's going to do, oh well,
I guess we do the bailout. Yeah. Although I think the bailout
you probably got to do anyway. So, but I I will say anybody who
thought, oh, maybe he could let the banks fail or something,
it's like he's never going to let that happen
regardless of if it was a good decision or not. I do I do think
it's indicative. >> It happened last night. So, last night,
I believe it was a little after midnight central time. So, was
maybe 1:00 a.m. 2:00 a.m. Eastern time, the US and Israel launched
a joint strike on Iran. And many people saw this coming. It was
pretty clear based on the military buildup in the Middle East,
the deployment of two aircraft carriers, the USS Gerald Ford
and the Abraham Lincoln, over a dozen destroyers, you had 50%
of the US deployable air power in the Middle East at the time
that the conflict broke out. In addition, the United States and
Israel had made steps to bolster their defenses. They deployed
missile defense systems like Patriot missile batteries and THAD
systems. The US moved its troops out of harm's way, called on
diplomatic personnel at embassies to evacuate. Israel opened
bomb shelters. So, it was very clear, as you know, that since
those protests in January, uh, about a month and a half ago when
the United States moved to deploy all this military power in
the region, that we were moving towards war. And last night,
we finally got it. And so, the US and Israel launched, I believe
now the tally is over a thousand air strikes on Iran. It appears
that the US and Israel has s have suffered no casualties. They
have complete air superiority over the western half of the country.
They claim they will have air superiority over the rest of the
country within 24 hours. The US and Israel targeted regime targets,
so centers of government, command and control.
Here I'm I'm listening to this a little bit, Canadian caller,
but this is interesting. You think the US just underwriting the
loans would have been better? Interesting. Maybe. I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know how you get that done. I don't know how you
like require hiring like a temporary workforce to get through
that and I don't know I don't know how reasonable that is. >> Military
leadership fortified bunkers. They also targeted nuclear sites
and that's not just Fordo Esvahan and Natans which is where they
enriched the uranium but also Busher where Iran operates a Russian
provided nuclear power plant. And lastly they targeted and this
is the big one regime military assets. So missile launch platforms,
their missile manufacturing cities where they actually have underground
an entire city to build their missiles. The US targeted their
navy, targeted their defense ministry, their intelligence ministry.
This is nice to get the rundown after the fact because this is,
by the way, this is another reason that I used to watch Fentes
is he actually just does a good job. He he like has researchers
who will go and and figure out the facts and the actual factual
reporting he does on stuff like this is just quite good and compact
like it's always um condensed. >> The executive function
of the military and all the hardware.
Very shortly after the strikes began and rumors surfaced of this
on social media video was posted. The president made a statement
and I have to tell you this was the most disturbing surreal thing
I think I've
Middle middle of the night he comes out gun to his head say the
Israel propaganda lines dawn Iran exports terrorism all over
the world they're the number one exporter of terrorism
maybe since the co >> Donald and if you saw this live you
know what I'm talking about the president posted a formal address
last night announcing the operation and discussing the goals
of the operation and some expectations about what will happen
and he announced it wearing no necktie in a baseball cap that
says USA in front of a black curtain by himself.
And without getting too much into this quite yet because we will
arrive there eventually.
Oh, this is very interesting. If you wanted to look at this psychologically,
maybe Nick will make this point. I didn't think about this until
he started like really analyzing. I was not pretty exhausted
last night, but Trump really cares about optics all the time.
It's like the number one thing he cares about is not even optics,
it's like his image. His image. He always has the power tie.
He always has the suit. He always presents himself in a very
specific way. Room full of people clamoring for his attention,
right? And then for this one, it's totally different. It's there's
no tie. He's got the hat on. It's like a totally different circumstance.
And realistically, Donald Trump, I believe, would just say, "We're
going to wait until the morning when I could sleep, and then
we're going to do an announcement when I'm ready to go." >> There
is something particularly surreal when you measure and weigh
the gravity of the situation. and its significance for the United
States. Obviously, the United States has been involved in the
Middle East for a very long time doing exactly this sort of thing.
Regime change, proxy warfare, fighting terrorism, ostensibly
deploying massive amounts of air, sea, and ground power.
And the entire conceit of this MAGA movement of President Trump,
the whole reason we're doing this nominally,
this was supposed to be in opposition to the Iraq war and to
the legacy of the Iraq war and all of the other associated interventions.
Now, we know that the same people that were behind the war in
Iraq, they're the same people that have that have been beating
the drum for war in Iran for just as much time. And they have
tried to pressure many presidents into doing this. This should
have been obvious from the moment that Nikki Haley went not Nikki
Haley the moment um Tulsi Gabbard came out was like Iran's not
like they don't even have close to the amount of enriched uranium
they've not been enriching that much uranium we don't believe
they have any capacity to move towards a bomb in the near future
and then Trump came out and goes Telsea doesn't know what she's
talking about the second that happened it should have been really
obvious to everybody what was going on and you should have been
able to like point it out pretty easily okay
it's just so obvious
this and they have moved the United States closer to a conflict
like this.
And so Trump being the one who was supposed to challenge and
oppose all of this, who repudiated it and created the successful
political movement, now to be delivering for the same people,
repudiating those people and their agenda, for him now to be
serving them, delivering for them what they have wanted for so
long. It's actually disturbing. It's disturbing what it says
about how our country works whether we the people are still in
control. Is this a government of, by, and for the people? Do
elections matter? Does the popular will matter in our representative
democracy in our republic?
If we vote to repudiate a policy, a foreign interest group, a
special interest group, repudiate a particular agenda, and we
get that agenda anyway, that war, those people, regardless, what
does that say about the political state, the actual true political
reality of the United States of America, if anything, it just
verifies what Trump said from the very beginning, which is that
we are no longer in control. The people are no longer sovereign.
And we knew that. That is something that we had always known
and we had always suspected. This is confirmation.
This is an illegitimate regime. The Constitution, representative
democracy, our republic is effectively over. You can vote for
a candidate that repudiates the global war on terror, the war
in Iraq, regime change, someone that explicitly promises not
to bring us into new conflicts,
someone that explicitly campaigns as the peace president, no
new wars, and you'll get all of it anyway.
We are in a state of distress.
This is not a republic anymore. That's over. And the MAGA movement
is surely dead, of course. But anyway, I digress. I watched the
speech last night. Very uncanny and disturbing and strange. And
you like the one thing I think Nick does poorly from a political
perspective is he does expect changes to happen too rapidly.
Okay, this is something he could learn from BB. Did BB crash
out when he didn't have all of those regime changes within 5
years? Nope. BB was playing the long game. That's how you win
in politics. You play the long game. You stick to your goals.
You play the long game. I think this sometimes when Nick says
stuff like the manga movement is dead, it's like you do pull
a lot of your your audience from the manga movement, you are
going to put them off. If it's purely about, you know, again,
something like realism where you're just everything you're saying
is going towards a goal. If it's a which I don't think it necessarily
is with Fentes. If it if you're just trying to achieve your goals
though, statements like that, they kind of pull the audience
back, right? They pull the audience back. BB is a politician.
Fentes is a media person. Fuentes wants political power though.
Fentes is trying to get as many people who believe what he believes
in positions of power. He endeavors to do that like all the time.
It's very it's it's a hybrid thing that is not the same as just
being a media person. He is not a media person the same way that
like Destiny or Hassan are media people, right? You don't hear
how like every every Democrat staffer is a Hassan fan or a Destiny
fan. You do hear that about Republican staffers in Fentes, though.
Um uh you could argue this simply substance. It's not something
calculated though. This guy is way less way less scientist, way
more artist in that way. Okay. way way less scientist, way more
artist, way more like on a whim he will crash the out and switch
up a lot of stuff. Maybe not the core underlying stuff, but he
will crash the out and he will like say things that do affect
him, do hurt him long term, but that's I part of it too. >> You
need to listen to the speech. >> That's what makes people
go, "Oh, he's really genuine." Like Trump's like that, >> Because
the speech lays out exactly what this is. Trump talks about the
entire history of US Iranian relations. He goes back to the 1979
Iranian hostage crisis to the Beirut barracks bombing in 1983.
He discussed Iran huge nick tweet. What is this going to be?
This going to be what is this going to be? Yeah.
Never Vance, never Rubio. The Iran war ticket just lost 2028.
I'm unfortunately going to retweet that. I hope I hope everybody
understands that there is nobody working harder towards Democratic
political wins right now. Democrat political wins than Nick Fentes.
Nick Fentes is explicitly committing to the strategy. I said
I think Hassan's committing to the long-term thing. Okay. Where
he is saying I I am not going to support this. I'm throwing all
my weight against this, right? Because longterm he thinks this
makes him look good. He thinks he is doing the thing where it's
like 5 years from now this position will be the correct position.
Dude, the dude unfortunately I got to retweet that as well.
Unlucky.
Unlucky, dude. It's It's wild. I wonder if they're boosting him
if who's boosting who. Okay. Yeah, you guys could say Hassan
gets swarmed. People know who Hassan is, but Hassan's like a
popular guy. He's not the guy who like the the new policy makers
are listening to. Okay. He's not. He's not. I love Hassan kind
of sometimes, but he's not the He's not the policy guy. He's
not the the ideas guy. Oh god. Amy Dangerfield. America first
or nothing. I don't even I don't even like care. I I would never
advocate for anybody on the Republican ticket until I see change.
I'd never advocate for one of them. But like objectively, they're
not following their own values. Objectively, they have a huge
part which is the core Trump base who are getting ignored and
like totally right now. They're in the chair. They're in the
chair watching BB their goat in the ass. Okay.
And it's disturbing. It's very disturbing. Use of IEDs and their
backing of Shiite militias in Iraq. What is the purpose of all
of this? What is the purpose of all of this history?
Well, he is making the case. As they say, he is making the case,
creating the pretext for a regime change war in Iran. And the
message is simple. The Iranian regime, obviously, Iran is going
nowhere. The territory, the population, they're not going anywhere.
But this regime which was thrust into power during the revolution
in 1979, Trump is making the case that they are an international
pariah, a threat to the United States, an historic adversary
of the United States, and therefore that is why they have to
go. So make no mistake about it, that rhetoric that he lays out
in the beginning of the speech, that's a regime change speech.
He is laying out the case. This is why the regime has to go.
That's not a speech about nuclear weapons. I mean, he pretty
explicitly, yeah, he lays out the reasoning, I guess, but he's
he's literally just saying the he's also saying we're getting
rid of the regime. So maybe I maybe I'm not even disagreeing,
but it sounds like Nick is saying you have to read between the
lines to see that it's a regime change war. No, I think he literally
just says we're getting rid of the Ayatollas. We're getting rid
of the Islamic Republic. We don't like them. >> Weapons,
missiles. It's not a speech about bringing them to the negotiating
>> Obviously, that's a regime change speech. Further, he
makes it even more explicit. He announced the targets of the
strike. He said that the United States and Israel launched a
joint operation targeting Iran's navy, its missile production
facilities, and regime targets.
You underestimate how dumb the MAGA loyalists are. Uh here's
the problem, Shimu. Here's the problem. And this has always been
the problem for these people.
Fentes taps into this stuff. He needs to be careful cuz it's
a fine line. He is like a total theater kid. He is not the kind
of leader the MAGA people would like to respect, but he is way
more tapped into how they think and what they feel emotionally
than anybody else. And he is capable of subverting this movement
at large scale. And he's shown it already. Okay? There's a reason
he could say, "Don't vote for Trump." And then say, "I didn't
vote for Trump." And then become like the most popular manga
influencer in the world. Okay?
There is a there's a reason for that. Now he has to be careful
because when he gets a little too um he's like playing a character
and the character has to become more dumbed down. And I think
he's basically in his soul he is against that. In his soul he
is this like intellectual theater kid artist. And while he like
lets that peek through and he makes it clear to his audience
that that's kind of who he is. Sometimes he lets it peek through
too much if he he so he's got to be careful cuz he's going he's
hardcore cutting against the the that audience right now. And
so he needs to not give them too many attack surfaces to go against.
Okay.
Viewer of the Propetto comments, viewer of the Catboy comments,
viewer of the, you know, I I think the I want to marry a PR thing
is actually inconsequential. But some of those he just needs
to not provide attack surfaces on like some of the ways he doesn't
map onto that coalition. It's a very bluecollar coalition. They
don't typically respect like total nerds and Nick is a total
nerd. So, you just got to watch how hard he plays into that sometimes
because you will lose people just on they'll just go, "This nerd
sucks. This nerd sucks." And they'll walk away, right? Um him
saying affordability is less important than the white majority
was really bad. I could see that being bad.
Yeah, you tell he thinks a lot of his viewers are stupid, but
that's okay. It's okay for him to be smarter. He just not He
has to not be a total nerd about it. Not He has to not be the
the His soul is that of a gay theater kid. Okay.
His soul is that of like a really smart gay theater kid and he's
needs to just hide that soul a little bit from people. Okay.
He called upon the Iranian Revolutionary Guard and the Iranian
armed forces to lay down their arms or they would die.
He then said that upon the conclusion of the operation, he invites
the Iranian people to emerge from shelter and to take their country
back. He effectively said, "I am giving you the opportunity.
I am neutralizing the Iranian government and its military and
the regime. and once we're finished, you will emerge and take
back your country. And so, every aspect of this speech is critical.
He is making the case that the regime must be toppled, talking
about destroying all of the regime's assets, killing all of their
personnel, calling for a complete and total surrender, and in
the end, after all that, calling upon the Iranian people to rise
up, have a coup, and install a new regime. So, again, make no
mistake about it. We have entered into a reg. I don't think Fuentes
is a very diverse viewership. Maybe I'm wrong. I mean, he might
have a less diverse viewership now that it's scaled up massively,
but he originally was quite famous for having explicitly like
a very diverse viewership. Okay, >> regime change. Hilarious.
>> Now, why am I saying this? Why is this such an important
thing to understand?
>> We have been at war. >> This stream just went
he just ended the stream it looks like on the other end. So,
I will keep listening. I hope it doesn't need to get relation
with Iran for decades. We have been in a state of war with Iran
by every other means. We have assassinated their leaders. The
Israelis have assassinated their scientists. With Israel, we
have launched cyber attacks on their infrastructure, not just
nuclear, but also other vital critical infrastructure. There
has been espionage, industrial sabotage. We have gone to war
with their proxies like the Houthies in Yemen. We have launched
strikes against their positions in other countries too. We have
been in a state of war for a long time. But because the objectives
of these other operations have been limited, people don't call
it a war. They say these are operations to neutralize the nuclear
program or this is meant to increase our leverage in negotiations
or it's some form of a proxy war and this is about rolling back
their soft or hard influence across the region. Well, tonight
nobody
can deny we are now engaged against Iran in a full This is sort
of what I was saying around the idea that you could so I I could
understand we could have a rational discourse around whether
or not bombing the centrifuges and using like the B2s in in service
of Israel's goals was a rational thing that could arguably be
in America's interest. Right? We could even if you you could
argue it's like a favorite Israel, but you don't do regime change
as a favor. You want to you want to make sure that this country
has less access to enriched uranium. That's one thing. This is
like a totally different step. It's a radically different step
that has to be acknowledged and can't be ignored. Okay, those
are the same thing. I just said the same thing. >> Full-fledged
regime change war. Now, what's more, as we discussed for the
past couple of weeks, everybody suspected that we would eventually
use this military power that is forward deployed against Iran.
The question concerning that operation is what the goal of that
would be and how it would be accomplished.
Now this matters very deeply because the kind of force that has
been deployed into the region as you have probably noticed is
a naval force and an air force and that is the operation. It
is a naval and an air operation. We have not invaded Iran. We
have not put boots on the ground. We don't have special forces
there. There has not been a major coalition invasion. We don't
have people parachuting in. How this operation is being conducted
is with missiles launched from ships and with air power. It is
with our carriers which bring the air. Now, is he going to make
the argument? Because I don't think people are making this argument
yet. I think you have to call for hey be transparent about how
much this costs. I think from the beginning we should get a total
commitment to transparency of the cost of this so America can
know just how much it cost us to send all of these assets to
the Middle East and then to bomb Iran to the extent we did. How
much did this cost America including include in there any aid
given to Israel on top of it. Okay. Any material military aid
that's being used by Israel to bomb Iran right now. Include all
of this stuff. You show me
how much money are we spending on this?
>> More power to the region. It is with bombers which have
been stationed in other countries. It is an air and sea campaign.
Now this creates a conundrum here because again if the goal is
the maximalist objective which is to topple the Iranian regime,
we are going all the way. Again, it's not about degrading their
capabilities. It's not about weakening them. If the goal is to
exterminate the Iranian regime, we're going all the way and toppling
them. It raises the question, how is that going to be done with
air and sea power alone? We now have the goal. We also now have
the mode. We know what the Trump administration is seeking and
we know how they seek to achieve it. But the problem that is
created is that historically you cannot achieve a regime change
through air and sea power alone.
Why is that? Because although you can bomb civilian government
facilities, you can bomb military facilities, you can destroy
the navy, you can destroy hardware, anti-aircraft systems,
on the other side of all of the bombing, there are still going
to be 200,000 Iranian Revolutionary Guard Corps soldiers and
they will be armed.
On the other side of this, you are still going to have all in
all all in about a million Iranian security personnel between
the IRGC, the Iranian armed forces and the internal security
forces.
This is the real problem is um like the extent to which they
have just a huge
base of power in the country. Like I don't think you can kill
you're going to have to kill substantial numbers of these people.
And I don't know how you do this in this urban area, right?
Um, this is what I was I was listening to Joanna earlier today
and this is the point she was making is like there's nobody who
has anything close to this in the region. Like literally the
regime doesn't have to send their commanders out of bunkers.
The regime can still control this, right? You cannot crush the
spirit of resistance. Well, you can you can crush it, but unfortunately
these people are in like a holy war,
like the the people in the IRGC, the people in the
the people in the Iranian army, they're they're all religious.
They are all like devout. And I don't know if anybody knows this,
but Kmeni was not just the like supreme leader of Iran. He's
also the Ayatollah. He is like a leader. He is like the is he
not the top of the top leader of the entire Shia religion?
I believe he's like the top like prophet leader. It's like killing
the their pope. Yeah.
Like you have to understand you just killed a guy who is going
to unite like opposition against you in a very specific way.